some of Travis's programs could have
been sustainable if he pursued a sound
economic policy but what about is
question of the day would love to hear
your feel what example would you use if
you're an advocate for socialism for
successful long term socialism to which
country would you point I'm curious
because John Oliver released this videos
we talked about the Venezuela video here
and he talks about how important it is
and there's there's there's nothing new
here really does end I really want you
to go watch the entire video what is it
about 19 about 19 minutes I encourage
you to watch the entire context we're
going to try to do our best to get to
the factual information presented there
is less and less with each done Oliver
video let's go clipping has been hard to
keep up with events in Venezuela due to
the hurricane that we've all been
dealing with here although if you follow
conservative media at all you might have
seen it frequently painted as the
inevitable dire consequences of a
socialist government for a case in point
just watch this Infowars reporter
quizzing an extremely chill Bernie
Sanders supporter your honor a majority
of the country is currently eating rats
while their politicians are drinking
champagne on a daily basis if Bernie
Sanders were president right and he
wanted to bring the same ideas as social
for socialism into this country why
should you dressed like Donald Duck do
you think that we would benefit yeah but
I just told you Venezuela is getting
rats I'm screwed Sailor Moon but I just
want build-up health care I don't want
like worms in your brain and honest
what you do up there is a nice
distillation of the current level of
political discourse in America to people
who don't really know what they're
talking about condescending to each
other nonsensically until one of them
lands a sick bird do you think I
actually agree with almost everything
you just said except for the sick burn
part and that's what's important air
we're gonna get to the examples a dad of
the facts and all of our sources in a
minute but if you think I just I just
want free health care you people have
worms when your head is a sick burn no
facts data or analysis thereafter and
this piece here can convince you all
right I just wanna make sure because we
just have to we disagree at that point
by the way it's a classic strong memory
he sits there and talks about two people
who have no idea what they're talking
about if it's if it's so lowbrow why did
you choose this example you could have
taken an example of Noam Chomsky and Sam
hare is talking about social you could
have this is what you pick but what is
happening in Venezuela it's not just
extremely important it is absolutely
worth paying attention to because this
is not just a story about socialism
there are plenty of socialist countries
that look nothing like Venezuela it's a
story about epic mismanagement but you
repeat yourself see the entire criticism
of socialism the entire reason that
conservatives the right-wing what do we
want to call us oppose a path toward
intrusive government is predicated on
the idea the concept as worth of
mismanagement for which we are roundly
mocked sums that capitalism designed to
prevent yes it's almost those designs do
management it no your the thing you
don't even have to believe that
capitalism is correct to agree with me
when I say that conservatives and
capitalists fear that socialism we
believe socialism to result in gross
mismanagement even even the United
States by the way so socialist but
socialism or government bureaucracy plus
time equals mismanagement equals failure
see examples and healthcare Social
Security education and banking gen
Albert goes on he goes on to say there
plenty of socialist nations we said in
that clip I think that looked different
from Venezuela implying success
now I thought and we've talked I thought
he's going to point to the the Nordic
model yeah as so many left us do even
attempt to do that or a little while it
looks like it's working until you run
out of people's money until the danish
prime minister says we're not so sure
yeah bernie sanders please shut up you
can call it democratic socialism you can
call it national socialism there
is no good socialism that's the only
constant and it always results in
mismanagement let's see and I've said
this before when we've covered what's
going on in Venezuela it is not one
thing it is not just the fact that it's
a socialist country it is under factors
that played a role in the economic
downfall of the country I'm not saying
that we all live in communist you know
the Soviet Union or China terrible
terrible things happen there but that's
what we always we always revert to you
know we say well is there not is it not
possible that we could for a start they
didn't do it properly they ignored it
thank you everybody says but no one's
ever done it properly
inevitably point you to the next brand
of socialism which will work or the next
leader who will do it better that's all
we've seen all of our current leftist
leaders and I'm not about extremists I'm
talking about your political leaders
we're all stars a platform representives
for the DNC praising all the previous
socialist and communist dictators who
end up being awful terrible people Fidel
Castro they forgot that he educated the
kids gave them health care totally
transform the society it would be wrong
my state that in Cuba they have made
some good advances in health care they
are sending doctors all over the world
fund AIDS they have made some progress
in education they can send doctors
wherever they want right if people don't
want the doctors that's like I could you
know I could go to the the Tokyo
Superdome I could say I perform at the
Tokyo Superdome but I didn't sell it out
I didn't sell out anything on raft and
the ref is this desk chair we're gonna
get out of there and you saw of course
we have the Beatle here of Obama and in
front of Che and the whole revolution
over it's just like oh my gosh let's
let's be reverent to a man who said
before the UN that they would execute
without trial and by the way hated black
people thought they were lazy and
deserving of death again you look back
they were praising all these socialist
leaders right in people it was actually
more talk about Castro but let me
matter-of-fact guess who found himself
amongst the figureheads worthy of praise
and his country is it possible maybe he
is one of the most important forces
we've had on his planet from my very
American
of my friend as an inch of is it is only
possible to be so inspiring as he is
sometimes American journalist talk about
how bad the country is because people
are lining up fools it's funny we write
these shows every day and we sit down
and when you really put it on time like
this
it's even more damning than I thought
they try and distance themselves from
the results yeah right that's what
happens here's the thing Bernie Sanders
didn't come out and say I was wrong
about bread lines it turns out there's
not free next day shipping he didn't
have a flash of genius moment he's still
a socialist he just slapped Democratic
in front of it and by the way they've
praised these peep this is again
mainstream leftism please go watch the
whole video you can go back and find
clips of John Oliver saying things of
the same effect so much it's so
embarrassing that John Oliver himself
even has to hedge his bets in his own
video and acknowledging how much the
left kind of loved Chavez to the fans
each others many of his social programs
were initially effective during his
tenure the poverty rate was nearly
halved and to this day many Venezuelans
revere Chavez to a dramatic degree
halved okay let's let's go to poverty
how well it's easy to cut poverty in
half when you use taxpayer dollars and
cease production just for a little while
if you just take all of all of the
monies and all of the things and you
know what you could also completely
unlimited unemployment if you forced
everyone to dig ditches with spoons you
could it doesn't mean it's a real
economy it gets propped up North Korea
did the same thing for slaver only works
for so long before you fall off the edge
and you had a point about that right
spin yeah I mean beep if they didn't
have oil you know they would have had to
build a wall around that country and
stuff their own people don't know how
good it is outside what happened what
they did you know what's great the left
has never called out on this crap this
is the problem with social him it's it's
like one of those things you get the
dollars with like a bar of soap it's one
of those party tricks that keeps
slipping through your hands
they're never called out Joe Biden was
talking about having meetings there when
he was running as vice president with
people he never met diners that didn't
even exist
right number the BP oil spill left lemon
an to talk about this afterward to talk
about the 18 billion dollar lawsuit that
occurred versus Chevron let's turned out
to be fraudulent they never get called
on the scrap because george w bush said
nucular because because because
president donald trump has a bad
comb-over you guys we're all praising
venezuela for years for years we can
sure we only have so much time on the
show and you were wrong you're always
wrong and the media never call how nice
it must be to never because i predict
just yesterday and supporting the
embassy called out for apparently taking
shekels from jews and Illuminati
no one's gonna call any of these people
out on praising chavez and bread lines
in venezuela you are on the left is
always wrong and i'm saying that an
absolutist yes absolutely as it relates
to socialism and no one calls him on it
i am amazed next clip now Chavez could
act the way that he did because
Venezuela was oil-rich and over the
course of his presidency he took more
and more state control over their
national oil company enabling him to
fund programs benefiting the poor and
when that company protested some of the
changes that he was making he responded
by using his TV show to address its
executives directly there Peter I'm
firing the following people mr. Juan
Fernandez you are fired from petroleum
of Venezuela Eddie Ramirez thank you
very much
you were fired
also Mariano Rodriguez you are not fired
but if you don't stop talking to your
boyfriend on speakerphone you absolutely
will be on the outset he's praising it
yeah watch the full video the full
context because you'd be like nobody's
gonna counterbalance it after him he
never does he literally takes an example
of one of I would argue one of the most
horrific displays of socialist
authoritarianism and he never dresses it
as horrifying yeah I think the words
government took control the state could
took controls oil companies then fired
executives can only generate one of two
visceral reactions disgust
freedom-loving disgust or admiration
we're saying the exact same thing you're
saying the state took control of the oil
companies and for executives I'm
thinking the state took control the Oh
companies in fired executives like I'm
saying listen you hear this the state
seizing control and firing executives
one of two reactions all right
disgust or admiration now now this isn't
a rebuttal right here okay I'm telling
you this we're not gonna find common
ground if you hear that and you're okay
this isn't a rattle it's a litmus test
right you have to figure out where you
line up next clip some of Travis's
programs could have been sustainable if
he pursued a sound economic policy and
run a tight ship but not only did he
stop saving oil revenues in a rainy day
fund he also oversaw a government that
transparency international found to be
the most corrupt country in Latin
America but what about is there is no
mention of is if he run a tight ship ha
yes the tight the tight ship policy this
didn't work with Venezuela okay if now
you're taking a big if with countries
that aren't rich in oil they were
starting off halfway through the foot
race as far as a head start all
Venezuela had to do was mat fumble it's
easy to see what Maduro has pissed
people off because he has managed
Venezuela's economic crisis in the worst
possible way he's doubled down on many
of Chavez his most unsound policies like
unrealistic currency and price controls
while attempting to make up for missing
revenue by simply creating more money
and as a result inflation has exploded
they're hedging here he used a lot of
hedge words is unrealistic okay
you guys remove that and just make
everything that he likes price controls
Democrats damn and I'm just saying
liberal progressives Democrats okay for
people out there like I'm on a classic
liberal no you're not
Democrats have actively supported price
controls for college for years Bernie
Sanders calling for price controls on
pharmaceuticals unrealistic printing
walkers printing war currency Obama's
economic economic philosophy was based
on quantitative easing
this is from Obama the feds mandate my
mandate is to grow our economy and
that's not just good for they say that's
good for the whole world so or thing
could happen in the world counties we
end up stuck with no growth at our very
listen the guy the left has caught you
look at the Federal Reserve understand
what that is under look at people the
most radical right leading people they
want to go back to a gold back standard
right this is something that
conservatives have been openly mocked
for opposing for years printing of more
cash it's a fundamental premise of the
left right as far as Keynesian economics
um by the way I learned Keynesian
economics in college never one shred
Adam Smith maybe John Oliver and I went
to the same College probably not alright
next clip and those shortages have had
some terrible consequences yes this food
shortage is widespread over the last
year three-quarters of the population
has lost an average of almost twenty
pounds look how fat I used to be this is
how many holes I had to make in my belt
on the Maduro the Maduro
diet that is actually now a commonly
used phrase in Venezuela and it's a very
healthy sounding term for a truly
horrifying situation okay I'm on a
second I'm that guy looks not bad he
must have been really fact picking the
wrong examples again yeah
starvation okay the years where we can
find common ground right we all agree
starvation is bad there we go but why is
there starvation why are there food
shortages what the government do with
food fix the prices that's textbook
social we just talked about fixing
prices we just talk about the left
opposing what they call price gouging
raising the price when there's lower
supply this results in chronic shortages
because the price is set to live he
literally after this just goes on to
make fun
Maduro and attack him for eating an
empanada honor it's a 19 minute video I
highly recommend that you go and watch
the entire thing there's almost no
continuation as far as critics easy to
find SATs top of the tourney it's at the
top of the tournament as far as
continuation of the policies any any any
criticism now why why is there no
continued criticism on the policies it
goes on to talk about what a jerk Maduro
is because the policies are either
identical to us we have Chavez or far
too similar to policies of today's
current left supports including John
Oliver so go watch the video see for
yourself it's on 19 minutes I want you
to watch it okay I want you to come back
and comment I want you to question our
sources I want you to get as much
context as humanly possible and make up
your own mind that's what I want you to
do and I see this with John Oliver more
and more and more and more you know I
used to start off where we would have to
go through a 12-minute video and go
through each source we scraped this
video for every single piece of factual
information he presented there's very
very little and I don't want to
fact-check jokes I don't want to jump on
a guy for telling jokes I think some of
the bits in there are funny but that's
not what this was about this has three
million places at the top of training
this is at the front page of HuffPo
because people like what he has to say
so we wanted to see what it was that he
had to say
and I think that you need to get as much
contact as possible make up your mind
because like I said okay if you think
the statements like I just want free
health care any of worms in your head if
you think that's a slick bone or if
you're hearing that the state seems
controlled production and fired
executive if that statement warms your
cockles there's no middle ground for us
ok this is something important a lot of
people's all we wants to be a leader no
I don't care as much about civility as I
do about honesty and we need to get to
the truth we find common ground starving
is bad we find common ground we don't
like poverty that's great that's enough
common ground we don't need to act as
though we're finding common ground on
economic policy that is evil you see the
results time after time after time after
time and you'd think it'd have egg on
their face because they praised people
who were evil in Castro in people like
Shabbos and I'm pretty sure you could
probably find them praising Maduro at
some point too because I mean really
we've we have clips of them praising
bread lines it's not too far-fetched to
say somewhere down the line Maduro got a
pat in the back from Bernie Sanders so
there's no middle ground here if you
just find those statements to be
heartwarming I disagree with you and
that's ok let us know hey if you like
this video subscribe or click the
notification but you should do both
anyways because youtube doesn't know too
by you if you're just subscribe you have
to hit that notification bell so if you
already are subscribed hit the
notification bell and if you're not
supporting this content go to lotta with
credit outcome / monk let me get the
fold nightly show an hour every day free
when you subscribe this hand - courtesy
mug as well as other programming and
listen you also get to support not Kay
Jarrod's Remicade treatment I don't know
what it is I know it has something
because he has he has he had ulcerative
colitis it doesn't anymore thank God
because their mood his colon and truth
be told it's not working very well
anyway